[Music]
get my good side news
this is submitted by like comment
subscribe hey yeah an ex-model who was
unhappy with her mug shot offered a more
flattering selfie to police that's
that's pretty funny no it's funny how
your brain changed there to her oh yeah
there oh it's a guy it's a guy [ __ ]
yeah well it looks like you know her is
in their word their hair yeah yeah in
there but yeah it's like actually a guy
yeah well it's all vain this
[ __ ] yeah he better be hot let
me see yep same is Mickey I can't slam
he's gonna skip keep his brand so this
guy's name is Stephen Murphy
we're Stefan no 33 years old from the UK
this is a mug shot that's the police
listed what da [ __ ] there's no other
[ __ ] angle bro
your face is [ __ ] maybe he's on bath
salts and he's like no I'm a model give
me I'm hot I'm [ __ ] high wow wow see
I'm gonna patchy maybe he's on bath
salts and he's like I got a better angle
for you just wait hold up you know those
goons from a Fifth Element yep yeah so
then he posted on Facebook cuz they puss
it is his mug shot on Facebook trying to
get him to come into the police
department and he puts it this would you
read it
we're gonna talk Porto Rican man ha ha
ha and if you get my name right and
don't put the worst picture of me on
these not when I've been up for three
days then in Boston cop shop for two you
might be how to find me post this better
for you what did he [ __ ] worship What
did he say this is the much that they
had you doesn't look better-looking on
the right though he's not I wouldn't
[ __ ] either of these two people as the
right he looks like he could be like on
the cast of Jersey Shore yes and then on
the left he looks like a alligator
wrestler geriatric Jersey Shore he looks
old
that is the Jersey Shore now yeah it is
now
oh there's a revamp a revamp yeah yeah
and everyone has crow's feet is that
right yeah it makes sense
did you guys see that one it's the the
two guys from Jersey Shore Joey and the
other guy and it's like a dating thing
word they had like a mansion and all
these girls are trying to get with them
have a smash room I [ __ ] love Jersey
sorry sure that's like Mike no can't
feel like got hotter she did yeah no he
did get out yeah should I go into her
look I was always I'm ready for the
[ __ ] hills to come back bro
that was my show I wasn't into that oh
that [ __ ] with the hills yes Spencer and
Heidi are still together I know Heidi I
am a you something popped up that like
about their kids or something I was like
oh [ __ ] there's something I just
remember she got a bunch of work done
like she's got big titties big ass lips
like like a hundred surgeries there's
some absurd amount i remember we talked
about that sounds like every girl in LA
100 almost every girl at those parties
and events I feel like this that's true
like so much work done and I'm like are
you a person in there and everyone makes
the same lastic they all look like they
a wannabe Kardashian yes I love it when
they're talking but you can tell that
they don't even know if their face is
moving yeah yeah
well they don't want their face to move
that's like there's like yeah I was like
this my boyfriend the other day yeah I
like the lips get stuck a little bit and
it's a freeze no don't
yeah and though use Botox and fillers
here Botox here and then fillers in the
lip so they're just like and he's just a
voice for a picture of Britney stop
you're such a [ __ ] that's really good
okay but back to this guy so he was mr.
Boston in the probably that's Wieland's
decent there he looks like a boxer like
a you know like a fighter he looks like
a fighter maybe cause it was this a
beauty pageant it's just the thing
something like that oh he looks manly
there's like a manly guy yeah do I just
picture with that picture he looks
friendly
the caption then you put like two cops
and chopped and then the shop there the
popular look everybody that's in this
other one oh God
new tattoo and Beckham heat your heart
out this guy doesn't know how to read a
riot it really doesn't he says heat your
heart out oh my god is he foreign
um I hope he's like Russian and he's
fairly learning that's a good question I
think he needs rosetta stone for english
he plays too much rugby yeah where's
native tongue is what he needs that this
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy's
next-level dude I think this time making
my Instagram like this I love that you
got emotional over them putting a bad
picture of him up maybe you but this one
instead of when I've been up for three
days came in like yeah look good that's
way too coherent for no that's not me
three days there's a cop shop to Big
John talk to me
exactly he doesn't know what and Eartha
is I more handsomer than this guy he
learned English without the conjugation
I thought it was funny that he had a
Hulk mask and he thinks that's scary
stupid years old that took steroids or
something and the caution tape is
amazing
into my room looking like that in the
dark I'd be pretty [ __ ] scared
someone with a cartoon mask on yeah
[ __ ] idiot
Oh get a skews like a toddler yeah a ski
mask I'm like oh [ __ ] but any guy that
has like face paint I just can't take
them seriously yeah but what if he's
doing this and he's like um get you
coming oh yeah British robots in he's a
British yeah maybe Boston from England
or some [ __ ] there's a city I guess mr.
Boston maybe that's true I'll be there
you know they spell color with the you
yeah maybe that's how they spelled it is
why he's all confused cuz he's from
England or where whose mind has both and
then everyone's be like but pack the car
and then he's like I don't know how to
speak now yeah now he's done yeah yeah
cuz he's from yeah Lincolnshire police
yeah that's in England okay yeah I'm not
[ __ ] up all right well how come he's
not saying jolly good or nothing like
that
Oh cheer Oh mornin totally good sir you
did mention something about boxing
someone oh yeah they did report that he
ended up posting a video of himself
speed boxing with the caption boom looks
like I have speeded it up lol I better
be careful they might put a most wanted
post out for a speeding ticket you've
got jokes
yeah at least he could construct a joke
[ __ ] English meathead yeah definition
of caveman I wish I knew him in real
life he compares himself to David
Beckham a lot Oh cut it out
that's time Danny looks different in
every picture though I know no more like
think of nowhere okay so he goes Beckham
heat your heart out which I'm guessing
is supposed to be eat your heart out
yeah but that's like something that you
flirt with a guy like a Steve eat your
heart out
you know like hell I want a friend like
this why don't we attract people like
this around us why easy where's Mowgli
maybe this cut there's a couple maybe
you're saying you want to follow people
like this oh I'm saying that I used to
have more friends like this or access to
people like this especially in high
school and sometimes when I went to
college but then my worlds kind of small
now well maybe you should go too
I should make new friends yeah okay go
back to your high school reunion
pick up a few I don't know those are
kind of sad I'll just go to high school
right now yeah yeah you can't go what if
we're life but what if I identify as a
17 year old
well that's true you could do that I'll
say like what if we're like this what if
we don't even know where this these
people and the regular people think
we're this that's how these people are
though that's the mentality yeah that's
true the catharsis so I don't think
we're normal
I know I'm not normal but we could spell
dare do it Joe oh [ __ ] you got a spot
that's right yeah or de ER mmm that's
where he [ __ ] that or DTR E there we
go there I do remember er E I remember
taking some pretty embarrassing pictures
back in a day though you don't make up
you took embarrassing pictures yeah you
me like you try to be sexy yeah like
when you're when you're in that weird
age where you're like trying to be
attractive to people oh yeah I came
across a lot of my like 15 year old 16
year old photos I'm like this will never
see the data like bro I feel gonna a 90
degree angle [ __ ] once where I was
like where the [ __ ] do I look the
[ __ ] scared right now oh where do I
get my whole body I look so skinny
doesn't this make your head look big
okay yeah but it makes your body look
small
outfit and if you kind of go on the side
you could probably see like I got curves
that was the myspace angle was more all
the way up here so that you could selfie
all the way down here and then I tried
to show like my entire like Oh cuz they
were tiny already yeah so doing this
forget it yeah use your body to sit here
[Laughter]
you took a lot how I want to see those
Oh all Bigham up for the other buns now
boomer you're just like this in all your
pictures right so I haven't had much to
smile about lately but all but we all
fake it well you don't have this that's
true that's true I guess I'm the realest
[ __ ] person that's in the picture Wow
way to make this video awkward now why
not sunny there you go you want to know
why are you there you go
[Music]
[Music]